[Music]
betty white didn't just get better with
age she got funnier and raunchier i have
loved pink's hot dogs forever and ever
so when they said they were gonna well
that's obscene when they said it was
wrong
do you think you can get away with it
more oh sure i'm 88 years old and you're
gonna get by with murder at this age
betty was born in illinois in 1922 her
family moved to los angeles during the
great depression after graduating from
beverly hills high school betty began
performing on radio and the experimental
new medium of television ladies and
gentlemen
this is the moment soon after she became
one of the first bona fide tv stars she
acted in and produced the hit 1950 show
life with elizabeth
which earned her the first of more than
half a dozen emmy awards in 1952. she
then moved on to star in date with the
angels
[Music]
in the 1970s white was introduced to a
new generation of fans with her
emmy-winning run on the mary tyler moore
show i know what i'm doing
just cue me and then stick a sock in it
we're all very grateful for the fact
that we love each other and we have
always gotten along just think of it as
one of those shows where we don't speak
that wouldn't have been any fun at the
age of 63 white landed one of her
biggest career breaks starring on the
hit nbc show the golden girls thank you
for being afraid
the show earned white another emmy and
two golden globe nominations and
introduced her to yet another new
generation of fans you know what i hate
doing most after a party trying to find
your underwear in the big pile
[Laughter]
after starting a popular snickers
commercial fans launched a facebook
campaign to get her to host saturday
night live in 2010. it worked and she
became the oldest and one of the best
hosts in snl history when i first heard
about the campaign to get me to host
saturday night live i didn't know what
facebook was
and now that i do know what it is i have
to say
it sounds like a huge waste of time
white parlayed that hosting gig into a
starring role in the tv land show hot in
cleveland which won her another emmy and
two sag awards i am rich
and now you're handsome in addition to
acting betty has served as the
ambassador for animal rights donating
hundreds of thousands of dollars to the
la zoo perhaps the only thing she
enjoyed more than helping animals was
being in front of the camera and when i
asked her what kept her going after
eight decades in hollywood she said it
was the eternal joy and gratefulness
for her career i've been around so long
they can't get rid of me
63 years is a long time to hang in at
this and who would have ever dreamed
that at 90 years old you'd still be
privileged to be asked to do stuff and i
am i don't take it for granted i taste
every minute of it
[Music]
you